um hello to miss horton thanks for
joining us on the programme this morning
what's the problem what's the issue
our members are asking for their pay to
be returned to pre-pandemic levels
during the pandemic british airways very
opportunistically used something called
fire and rehire to force our members
into accepting a 10 pay cut and these
are some of the lowest paid workers in
the airline and all they want is to have
that 10 pay cut reinstated they want to
help british airways get back to
pre-pandemic profitability and they
think the best way to do that is to
invest in their staff to ensure that
recruitment and retention is in place
and our members have been experiencing
extremely high levels of verbal and
unfortunately in some cases physical
abuse which has been brought about by
the lack of preparation for the
reopening of the industry and it's
really on the back end of receiving this
abuse and the frustration that they're
experiencing that that they've had
enough and they've they've been asking
nicely now for over a year for british
airways to reinstate this 10 pay cut and
ba just start listening
so tell me more about some of this
physical abuse that your members have
been at the sharp end of
they've had to be escorted out of the
airport by police they've experienced
homophobic abuse
they have been spat at
um i had one woman this wasn't at
heathrow but at birmingham airport where
the ceo has just been awarded a 50 pay
increase uh a ticket agent passenger
service agent working for one of the
largest ground handling companies in the
country was pulled over the ticket desk
by a male passenger
out of his frustration and her
colleagues had to have to assist her
so just to clarify in birmingham
somebody dragged one of your members
over the ticket desk
that's unbelievable what happened
well her colleagues thankfully sort of
managed to pull her back and and these
workers they're not on much more than
the minimum wage okay
um and they love working for the
aviation industry they've done it for
many many years they want the industry
to get back on its knees and and they
want to help families to start flying
again but how can they do that when
they're being treated like this
um
given that we know that the government
is against um fire and rehire given what
happened with p o and they stepped in
there saying that it was completely
against the government's uh opinion and
position what's grant shaps doing to
support your union
very little okay um i i don't accept
that this government is against fire and
rehire um hugh merriman was very
outspoken about it during um the british
airways attack on our members
to suggest that the government is
against fire and rehire but to then make
it harder for workers to try to fight
back and win back what they had taken
from them as a result of firing me
higher during the pandemic doesn't
really stack up for me
um
do you acknowledge or to what extent do
you acknowledge that by go if you do go
on if your members do go on strike
they're going to cause absolute chaos
for travelers who just want to get away
on holiday with the kids
the point of a strike is obviously to
organize it at a time when it is going
to be most effective and most disruptive
our members have had to jump through
anti-trade union laws to get to the
point of even being able to hold a
democratic industrial action ballot that
they've that they voted in and our
members don't do this lightly and you
will have heard it been said many times
before the strike is a last resort and
as i said at the start we've been asking
for british airways to reinstate this
pay cut for well over a year now and
where we've ended up is is our members
feeling that they're not being listened
to
and so they've had to take matters into
their own hands and use the power that
they have available to them through a
democratic legal industrial action bala
and yes it will cause disruptive
disruption and yes my members and i are
genuinely sorry for any disruption that
that is going to cause to hard-working
families who so desperately want to get
away after not being able to fly as a
result of the pandemic but what our
members are doing here is defending
their living standards they just want to
be able to have a decent standard of
living they are primarily women many of
them part-time i've spoken about verbal
and physical abuse that they face
they've got families to look after as
well and this isn't just about them
being able to have a holiday this is
about them being able to put food on the
table
coordinated strike action is something
that's been suggested by the rmt union
is that something that your union would
support
we're not we're not having behind closed
doors discussions about coordinating
industrial action when industrial action
happens
it happens organically
it happens when working people have had
enough and they've decided that they
need to use the power that they have
available to them to withdraw their
labour
if there is an opportunity
to coordinate industrial action and and
look disputes don't run on a on a linear
line you know there's lots of ups and
downs and there's bumps in the road and
there's negotiations to be had and
there's decisions to be had about when
it's the appropriate time to organize
industrial action but if coordinated
industrial action is the right course of
action and that is what is decided by
our reps and our members because they're
the ones that call the shots in this
process we're a democratic organization
and it's our reps and members that make
these decisions if that is the right
course of action then i don't see any
reason why we wouldn't so you would
support a summer of discontent
no uh it's not about support in a summer
of discontent kay it's about working
people having had enough it's about the
fact that the ceo of british airways
gets paid
848 000 pounds and the ceo of iag
the parent company of british airways
gets paid 4.9 million pounds it's about
the fact that british airways paid 1.6
billion pounds in dividends out to
shareholders when it was profitable
prior to the pandemic instead of
reinvesting that money into its staff
and into things like it systems to make
sure that that that the airline is able
to function properly it's about the fact
that working people have seen the
sharpest decline in their living
standards in two decades and it's about
the fact that working people have had
enough and actually that they see that
there is some hope in standing together
collectively and organizing and if this
is the spark that lights the flame that
leads to worse you there do forgive me
come back and talk to us
next week or whenever you'd like to
thanks very much indeed for joining us
on the program